[LAUGHS]
Want me to get it?
Oh man, that's beautiful!
Now I've got butter
running down my arm,
and that's always a good thing.
This bread is delicious.
So Tim, we're all
going to be spending
a lot more time at
home, it's fair to say,
over the coming
weeks and months.
It's now the time to get
back to proper home cooking.
It's important to have
a few basic things that
might be useful.
I thought today we'd
start off by doing
a really simple loaf of bread.
Have you got your gear?
I've got a mixing bowl, yeast.
Real yeast, right?
Proper yeast?
This is fresh yeast.
All I've got is dried yeast, but
they're roughly the same thing.
So get your bowl
on your scale...
Yep.
...and then just weigh into
that 500 grammes of flour.
I've often heard people
say baking is a science.
You have to really be precise.
Oh yes, absolutely.
All that stove top nonsense with
flame and fire, that's easy.
This stuff is serious science.
I'm using strong bread flour.
I had to hunt high and low
for this strong bread flour.
It's not everywhere
at the moment.
People have emptied the
shelves in a lot of places.
If I had another type of flour,
could I do something similar,
or does it have to
be the bread flour?
You can do this with general
purpose regular flour,
not self-raising,
but regular flour.
You can do it.
You probably won't get as nice
a crust or as nice a crumb,
but you'll be able to get a
perfectly working, serviceable
loaf.
I want to measure 7 grammes
of the yeast in my case, 15
grammes in your case.
15 because I'm using
the fresh yeast.
...onto one side of the flour.
Now, where I'm pouring
mine, you crumble yours
onto the other side, pour
in 10 grammes of salt,
and weigh 350 grammes
of a tepid water right
into the middle of that flour.
Now, you are going to get
really floury and messy.
You're going to
use your fingers.
Mix it and blend it.
This is where it gets
therapeutic there.
This is still feeling
quite wet in my fingers.
Is that all right?
This does stay wet.
Don't worry about that.
Now, here's a really
weird question.
Do you travel much with work?
Well, not at the moment.
In the past, I used to, yes.
Are you one of those people
that nicks the shower caps?
I don't think I've
ever done that.
See, I'm the only bald man in
the world who nicks the shower
caps, but the shower
caps in hotels
are really, really good
for covering dough.
Then you can see inside how
the dough's rising, but listen,
don't worry about that.
I've just admitted that.
At least my stockpiles are of
something relatively benign.
Cover it up with the
a piece of damp cloth.
Over the next hour or so,
come down and check it,
and see if it's sort of
starting to move and puff up.
Just having a look
at this thing,
it looks kind of gelatinous.
Should I be worried about that?
No, that's really, really good.
You know, when people
think about bread usually,
they think about
kneading it a lot.
This gelatinous quality means
that the gluten's breaking down
without having to be beaten up.
What you need to do now
is get your hands wet.
Turn it, and kind of fold
it on itself a few times,
stretching the dough and
lifting it into the middle
and making a little tight ball.
And then put the cover
back on to leave it
for a couple more hours.
The more times you
stretch and fold,
the stronger the gluten
becomes, and therefore,
when it puffs up, it's really
going to go like a rocket.
Think about it as a sort
of a day-long process.
How is your dough looking?
It's looking pretty firm.
Oh, don't shake it!
Don't shake it!
No, no.
That's looking pretty good.
Is that looking good?
That's good.
Stop joggling it about!
You'll let all the air out!
I'm being a little bit
too enthusiastic there.
Be gentle, gentle with it.
Now watch.
Here we go.
Take the lid off, and check it.
My lord, that looks beautiful.
Yes.
You need to create some enclosed
environment in which it can
cook hot and hard and quickly.
So we're going to do it
inside one of these pots.
Why one of these pots
and not kind of a more
conventional bread tin?
A bread tin would work.
You could easily put
it into a bread tin,
but it won't be so pretty.
Put a squirt of oil into it.
We're going to put a
little bit of flour
on the table in front of us.
Pour the dough out, the kind
of crusty top of the dough
goes down onto the flour,
and the wet underside
stays upright.
Reach it onto the far side.
You put your fingers
underneath the dough, kind
of lift it and fold in
like little rabbit ears,
then you turn it round
and pull in rabbit ears
on the other two corners.
So you're pulling these
little things into the centre.
And if it sticks a bit,
put a bit more flour dough.
Do you see how it's sort of
tightening up into a ball?
Once you've got it
reasonably tight,
and it's kind of holding
together, chuck a bit
flour in it, flip it over
so the neat side is upwards.
Watch this movement.
So you're kind of getting
your fingers under it
and turning it.
You're tightening it.
And you can probably already
see in the surface of it
that there's little
bubbles forming and stuff
happening underneath.
But that stretchy
skin you're making
is what's going to hold
the bugger together.
Finally, put your hands
right underneath it,
pick it up like that, move it
over the top of your Le Creuset
and gently drop it
inside just like putting
a baby in the bath.
And shall I push it out a
little bit so it fits there,
or just leave it?
No!
Don't you dare!
No.
Quite the opposite.
Let it do that by itself.
Let it expand
against the outside,
do you see what I mean?
And when it's doubled, we slash
it and put it in a hot oven.
The bread has risen beautifully.
Yours looks great.
It looks better
than mine actually.
Really?
Mine's still quite
flat, yeah, but I've
used a bigger pan than yours.
So mine's probably
too large a one.
Cut a big slash in the
top so the bread opens up
and the cross comes
up through it.
I'm a bit nervous
doing this because it's
kind of stretching and
deflating the dough somewhat.
That's fine.
Don't worry.
Take your glass of water,
open the oven door,
put this inside
right at the centre,
and then throw the half
glass of water into the oven,
not into the pot.
Steam transmits the heat a
lot faster than just dry air.
Also the steam gelatinises
is the outside.
It gives it that lovely
sort of rubbery finish
which then crisps
off as it bakes.
OK, it's the moment of truth.
And it smells fantastic.
Oh man, that's beautiful.
Yeah?
How does that look?
That is staggeringly good.
OK, so shake it a bit.
Is it loose in the pot?
Yeah.
Just basically turn
your loaf out onto it.
There goes mine.
Out it goes.
Oh yes!
Oh mate, that is just superb!
It's making a satisfying noise.
That's a fabulous sound.
Now mine's actually
come out with a more
sort of foccacia-like crumb.
Mine would have been
good in a smaller tin,
so it would have raised higher.
That's not bad.
There's a good
distribution in that,
so all the little air
bubbles have gone through it.
What do you reckon?
Pretty good.
Yeah.
Salty butter or unsalted
butter are you using?
Salty of course.
Has to be.
I also find it incredibly
rewarding as well as delicious.
Oh, now I've got butter
running down my arm,
and that's always a good thing.